one of my favorite youtube channels is
quinn's ideas
i can hardly remember there was a time
when i didn't watch it
quinn's idea started out recovering
mostly dune with some game of thrones
mixed in but in the last two years he
has broadened his coverage to also
include foundation hyperion and the
works of hp lovecraft
thus it appears quinn and iya have
everything in common
so it didn't come as a surprise he
started his own fiction project the
fantasy comic tajia
while i'm relatively new to reading
comics thanks to quinn i have delved
into neil gaiman's the sandman and
jodorowsky's the in-cal
now after two years what started as an
indiegogo project has finally been
completed with the first volume tadya
exordium being released to backers
and this is a review of the digital
version
while watching quinn's dune videos you
quickly get the impression that the
all-female ben and jesuit are amongst
his favorite characters in frank
herbert's fictional universe
they are certainly mine
that combined with some other influences
ensures tadia would be about witches and
witchcraft
but before i analyze tatya in detail let
me describe what it is about
tarya starts when two witches approach
lord stefan in the night about the
bargain they have struck decades back
in favor of being lifted lifted out of
poverty and into the nobility stefron
would give the witches his eldest
daughter as you may guess
stefan is not keen to honor the bargain
but unlike other instances of this trope
he is not stupid either
the witches command him to leave his
home unguarded
this leaves the witches of hekate an
opportunity to impregnate his eldest
daughter using magical means
from which tadya is born
the headstrong child appears fascinated
with the old legends of the witches and
the ancient enemy baelor
the latter is on the rise but can only
send fragments of himself into the realm
they are called fomori
these are capable of possessing humans
and are responsible of a number of
murders
tadia and her new chambermaid ethita
decide to stop them
while ultimately successful by the end
of exordium it is discovered that the
witches of hikari allowed one of them
for boys to pass from otherworld to this
realm in order to activate taijia's
special powers
their intentions for this remains
unknown
what struck me first and foremost about
tadia is how quinn has created a fully
fleshed out fictional universe with its
own rules and rituals
this path can be both fun to do for any
author but also hard to get right
i know how it can be done from the
method described by arthur arson scott
card from his non-fiction book how to
write science fiction and fantasy
queen stadia feels like this as if it is
one of the better thought out fictional
worlds
tidia exodium is ripe with many
influences from popular culture as
mentioned there is a fair amount of
inspiration from the banerjester's
sisters from dune in the sisters of
hegarty
their powers and independence being too
noteworthy
but i also see influences from
cinderella especially with tardies
difficult relationship with her mother a
stepmother i must say
the evil named bailor and this femorian
stem from irish mythology
dungeons and dragons also has an evil
named balor although i am not certain
if quinn was influenced by it
finally there are parallels to the
sandman comics by neil gaiman
there is a similar importance to the
dream world
there are also familiar tropes within
tadia
the sisters of hekate are witches who
live in the forest
their lives and power are underfed from
a new religion whose god is
whose god is referred to as the father
with its own bible called the holy tone
thus the feminine naturalist world is
threatened by the masculine artificial
world
one of the best parts of tadia exordium
is the artwork
the drawings made by matthew belden
blends medieval realism with fantasy the
setting and characters have considerable
detail and a lot
and add a lot to the sense of immersion
this is topped off by the wonderful
color palette used by colorist jean
francois bolio
the dark blues of the night the glow of
the halves inside the room and the
amazing color explosions caused by magic
are unlike anything i've seen before
i am not certain how much both artists
have cooperated on this book but it
feels like they did
both styles enhance each other and the
story
tadya could have been a book
and it had been a book no doubt the
second volume would have already been
released
but this comic book is something special
yes i can see many influences within
tadia exordium
consciously or not
but i think talia succeeds on its own
just as well
while i would have loved it while i
would have loved it to be a longer comic
book it is surprisingly effective as an
introduction or beginning which is what
exordium actually means
tatia's journey in the story is a
complete one as she battles the forces
of balor
there's even a lengthy prologue that
reminds me a lot of the sandman comics
with its theme of betrayal and broken
promises
exodium is such a self-contained story
while a cliffhanger is present it does
not dominate
i hope quinn will manage to continue
this series
i think exordium is a labor of love that
lasted almost three years
no doubt a second book
should be produced more quickly
i understand there are some production
difficult difficulties culminating in a
change of letter
i think that haste
is the cause of one or two typos but
they are not a big deal
i hope i will get my hardback copies
soon
tadia exodium was not meant to be read
from a computer screen
check out the link in the description
for the indiegogo page for tardia
also don't forget to check out quinn's
channel
finally if you've if you have enjoyed
this video then please click the like
button
if you want more content like it then
please hit the subscribe button that
will help my channel grow